okay welcome everyone we should have
some very interesting discussion this
afternoon is a hot topic and of course
we want to work better with China for
for the future of the planet not be
making enemies of each other but we all
want to build better cities happy cities
green cities and communities where
everybody works together so that's the
purpose of AI and smart cities to help
people not take away their jobs right
okay so I'm going to be the moderator
and this is the order of the speaker so
as me all over you when the and the
young meanly and you already have our
our BIOS but we have a brief
introduction so my background is here
right what's relevant for this talk I
taught in China for two years at the
second floor language institute in
Beijing my Chinese was pretty fluent
right and then I lectured at the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs and I
lectured at pay dock at pea toss English
name is what Beijing University okay so
when you're there you kind of get you
know embarrassing that you forget the
English right okay so then I was a
Chinese computer software representative
in China actually the company that I
work for was Tenma or was international
geo systems they invented the first
pinyin Chinese input method and I could
type 120 words a minute in Chinese
because Chinese syllables are short and
with chin ma we don't have to use tones
because after eight characters it
figures out what's the right character
and that's that's how people understand
things when they listen although
sometimes tones can mess us up if they
get the wrong tone right okay so
I've been working on smart city and
smart grid development I was in Beijing
and nineteen her 2006 and seven right
working on the sacred and and those
smart city projects and then since 2008
I've been on the board of the us-china
green energy Council which is us-china
green energy so it's a promoting
collaboration between the two countries
and then I worked on with Heather Manus
which is a city planner and they did
they plan cities they've got about eight
cities in China that they planned and
I'm actually currently working with them
again on two city projects 120 ones in
Xi'an they're trying to modernize make
it a sustainable smart district at the
same time as that they want to promote
their ancient history and culture right
so they're they have kind of divided
loyalties as they develop yet they need
to go together so it's just a question
of you know bridging the way people look
at things and that's what AI is supposed
to help us do okay then that's it for
that part okay I've been also working
with Steve Cheung he's doing he was the
inventor of the supercomputer called
Cray right and then since since he left
gray he's been working in China
developing healthcare supercomputers and
community development connectivity using
supercomputers so he's joined us with
these two projects and we're the three
of us three companies are working
together on that okay the this is the
global standard right the United Nations
so there's 17 things you need to do to
make a city really sustainable and smart
and friendly and all that right and
that's a global standard China's a
member
I see Jim fingers gone there and they
joined it so there this is a background
for any development we do with smart
cities and and green cities will use a
that standard of course look I'll talk
about standards in a minute
current five-year plan of China is about
smart cities or one big part of it as
smart cities that are integrated with
agriculture so it's like they turn a
green city smart cities they grow food
they they take care of waste and all
those things right so that their that's
their vision now implementing it we all
know implementing stuff like that is
hard because different people understand
things differently I had a book that I
used to use when I was teaching world
history and the opening preface has said
the meaning of history is determined in
the day of judgment I said oh no this is
a dogmatic religious book then the next
sentence is the day of judgment is when
you read it and when you read it you
know about the blended and the elephant
we all see only part of our experience
so we interpret based on what we
currently believe are used to believe
and we know you know lots of people that
do that but we actually all do that so
we have to be continually that are
learning okay so this is a model of
using resources and fullcycle
remember waste management so everything
can be reused and the planet only has a
limited number of resources if we waste
them then we don't have them but they
all can be recycled because there's
nothing can be created or destroyed it
can only be transformed so this is a
model for reusing everything and
I worked for a biomass conversion
company so that's kind of like a key
item in this thing it takes biomass it
teaches up to a high temperature it
becomes a gas and then you separate all
the gases into their elements condense
it back down and then you have raw
materials to use it's expensive to build
but boy it saves a lot of money really
but this is all about the whole cycle
right so you don't have to convert
everything with high temperature now
this is we have a lot of arguments about
energy you know do we want to use coal
do we want to use atomic energy do we
want to use human energy well actually
if we want to optimize our community we
need to use all of it some of it is only
used for special things but you know
every piece of it can be useful okay
standards now I work a lot in standards
and I was a first editor of the Unicode
standard which puts all the language of
the world into one standard so that it
can be used on any computer if you have
the fonts so but standards and key
performance indicators how do you
measure things how do you get a
measurement of what's good and what
isn't or what what is the result what is
it how do you measure it
that's PK eyes and one of the things
that is difficult in China but
everywhere if you're going to measure
things that compare if you don't have a
standard then you don't know apples and
oranges that just how do you work
together so standards are very important
but then you know when I worked in China
back in a while ago if you try to create
a standard for okay how do you generate
an energy how do you measure it how do
you exchange energy for one kind to
another and I would recommend they put
solar roof capture the wind capture
ground source geothermal put them all
together in a building and then the
building can share it with others at the
community and the people that translated
it as a Chinese use of that
what in the world are you talking about
the state grid controls everything all
energies controlled by the state grid so
you know trying to talk about a building
managing sound energy is stupid
well that was not too long ago but we
know that it is stupid that not to think
that way but that's the bottle that they
had and Oliver is going to talk more
about that okay so then we want to
create green buildings Bart energy smart
communities or smart people and if you
try to turn everything over to
artificial intelligence we're lost we
become a victim we need to use our
official intelligence it's a tool for us
but we have to make people smart make
city smart and so forth ok today's
seminar plan is however you will talk
next to compare AI applications to power
systems in China and the u.s. comparing
them and how do we are we going to be
able to talk to each other next will be
when the youth emergence of AI and
Chinese smart city he's worked on a
number of projects in the US and China
he specializes in that making systems
that will measure it control it make it
available to exchange and so forth and
last forth was going to be young Li who
used to work for or he still where I
guess the channel national gas
corporation but he used the word work
for them now he works for our company
that he created that serves them but
he's also doing some smart city projects
right so we'll hear what how he's
managed to switch over to that or
integrate those things and then we'll
have questions than to it's questions
thank you okay thank you Jim welcome
good afternoon my name is all over you
actually I'm a fellow board member of a
organization called us-china we energy
consult with Jim and this
council promotes green energy between
China and the US
so I'm also the director for Smart Grid
task force for that council and so Jim
is one is mainly interested in focusing
around the small city part of the green
energy console and I was focusing mostly
on the smart grid and obviously there
are connections between these two
however that smart grid is mostly
infrastructure and that can be also
distributed and it can be also be
centralized
so therefore today I'm going to talk
about a comparison of artificial
intelligence applications to power
system in China and the US first I want
to give you a little bit about my
background
I have a bachelor's degree in electrical
engineering from National Taiwan
University and a Master degree in
electrical engineering from Georgia Tech
then I have a PhD in management science
and engineering from Stanford for many
years I worked for two research
institutes one is the Stanford Research
Institute which is now called Essaouira
international and the other one is the
electric power research institute both
are a good month in the Bay Area and so
after every Electric Power Research
Institute I was in charge of the
planning and analysis for the future
changes in the energy industry as well
as the allocation of the funding from
the utility industries to the
researchers so if Electric Power
Research Institute is a research funding
agency we're very much like National
Science Foundation on the other hand
Essaouira International is a contract
Research Institute and as probably many
of you know is one of the larger
independent Research Institute and was
established by Stanford University in
1946 and over the last 70 some years we
had over 3,000 breakthrough innovations
and some of them are you're familiar one
is the mouse was invented bass was
before the there was a PC in 1968 and so
we licensed the to Xerox Palo Alto
Research Center and they could not
commercialize them either
not until 1972 when Steve Jobs came to
visit a Xerox PARC and saw the prototype
for PC and also the mouse so therefore
he was very much inspired and went home
and get ideal to prototype the mouse to
what we have today and 40 years later we
embedded the theory which is the for fo
forerunner of all these artificial
intelligence you use in laksa and from
Google and from Amazon it is the voice
recognition system and command system so
when I was there I was also in charge of
energy and technology strategies for
various power companies in the world and
also I visited China quite often and so
so what are the differences between
China and the US well they are
fundamentally different in the following
way for four thousand years since the
Qin Dynasty the one who did built the
Great Wall and the one who gave China
the unified characters the words we use
today and also give us the name China
came from Qin okay that's why it was
called China
and has always been a centralized plant
economy centralized plant system even to
today and the China under the the
president's chief okay on the other hand
the US over the last 250 years as
generally being a decentralized system
and I also a decentralized economy okay
so those are the fundamental differences
between these two and so when I was
working on the smart grid and the you
were in the US we're talking about how
to apply smart grid to distributed
systems okay and but in China they don't
like the word smart with what they want
to call is called a strong grid
basically they want to have a
centralized grid that would really
control the entire system this can be
exemplified when I was first time went
back to China I was born in China but
then I left in China in 1949 then I went
back to China in 1978 as a delegate for
the US energy and power industry and
when we went to visit that time in chen2
they have this control system okay and
so I went with people in the u.s. power
industries at that time and so the first
question we were asked by the Chinese
professionals in the power control
system incentive is that how do we how
much can we learn from you to pull
people's plugs in which we will have
power shortage our ideal system would be
if we have a line go to each household
when there is a shortage I can just shut
down the electricity supply
and so we will not have overall blackout
we have small blackouts and so the us
utility power utility people were really
feeling a gas this day we could not do
that in the US because we'll with a
guest suit by the customers okay and
then did the Chinese power control
people say they cannot sue us we are the
country government okay there's no way
to sue us and we are protecting them
because we don't want to have widespread
blackouts so therefore we want a direct
control for every user okay so that's
exemplify the kind of difference in the
philosophy about how to run the power
system and how to apply technology okay
now that's also exemplified that there
are mainly two major grid one is the
state grid company as meant Jim
mentioned earlier which is about 80% of
the Chinese control system and there's a
Southern grid which is in the south part
of in in Guang centralising Guangdong
system well known province and again
that they want to have mainly direct
control of all the other users in the in
this system in contrast in the United
States
gradually first of all we have many many
more of great system and we have nine
regional reliable council within the
reliable account so we each one has
several major power grids so therefore
we have many more decentralized power
control system and also in recent years
there has to be a very strong movement
towards a distributed system
and that that really is a one of the
first major revolution in the electric
power industry as we all know that in
early days that electric power companies
in the US are monopolies
they're called regional monopolies they
the there was a bargain that was
construct by a famous person named he
was the his name suddenly escaped my
memory he was the Secretary to Thomas
Edison and then yeah he's from England
and he came as secretary for Thomas
Edison then he start to think there's a
very rural quest I'm sorry
very ruk ruk ative way to make money and
that would be to create regional
electric power monopolies by working
with the government to say that the
power companies will supply ile reliable
electricity so the bargain is that power
company in the US will supply reliable
electricity in exchange for the
monopolistic rate rate system that rate
system and so they're faster faster so
therefore there's a major difference
between them that time we have a
centralized power system then later on
when we have these renewables we have
these independent producers then the
customers start to generate power by
itself therefore we have that now it
much more decentralized system and
so that's a major revolution in the
power industry
and the cost that decentralization as
well as the irregular sheen of the power
industry and so that has not happened in
in China so if we look as some the
research they are doing today applying
artificial intelligence in China versus
the United States in China basically
they wanted strengthen the centralized
system and in the u.s. they want to
really to start to build the distributed
system so those that will be the two
major differences in the application of
AI and however I see there is a movement
towards decentralization in the in China
as well
largely for the second revolution in the
power industry that is the we call edge
computing I don't know anyone is
familiar with that the edge computing
basically this should be the computing
and that is now forcing the centralized
system to be much more decentralized so
echoing what Jim will be talking about
this China dream the China dream is to
have a harmonious society to have really
well smart energy smart buildings and
smart communication and smart
environment and so that maybe gradually
will be a convergence of the centralized
in the distributed system the only
caveat I want to mention is that the
smart that I'm sorry the China dream
which was promoted by President Xi is
very different from the American dream
we are here in America when we talk
about American dream
what is it to most of us is that we will
be individually become wealthy in half
home have a money and so
we can really enjoy ourselves in China
the China dream is for the country to be
strong to be leader in the world not
individuals
as you can see that lies the difference
between these two systems thank you
thank you
[Applause]
so we'll have to think about I mean
there's this so this looks to me like
it's too complicated for central to
control right so there has to be a way
in and people to selfish they're going
to cause problems as well right so we
need to think about that community I do
only know I might help you find it or
yeah
hello everyone good afternoon my name is
a well do just a little bit background
the first time a currently CEO of our
media's control which are commedia
controls now say so we provide a
security services for data center data
centers our fundamental infrastructure
for making cloud in the big data so it's
a it's a physical buildings or infant
structures where you put all your
servers or network of switching
equipment fiber updates all together and
if you have a hundred hundreds or
thousands of those things they form a
cloud which connects all your mobile
phones smart devices or together that's
what they do the data center so we
provided securities for data centers so
I'm not current CEO before archimedes I
was a general manager and representing
for GDS you in China for some of you may
not be familiar with JDS UK TSU
California no Peters base of the company
in a long time in the 2000 the GDS year
was similar to today's Google's that was
the single largest market cap company in
the world
today is a little bit different story
so I spent about nine years and you try
not going back and forth I was the
expert and I was sent to China so
builder China organizations and business
and the sales marketing or some other
parts of the countries so I had amariah
fortunate times in the spending years of
seeing how China developed from 2006 and
when returned back to the US was nine
years later so I would like to share
with you some of my experience and what
I saw when I was in China they're part
of GDS unifies I was CEO and the
chairman for three start-up companies in
the back divided Silicon Valley in the
Boston venture capitalism and we're
fortunate enough for and silly startups
or acquired one of them it was a
semiconductor company and I know there
was networking companies and I know that
was a internet-related a company's scuse
me as a microphone working okay okay Amy
okay that's good and a part of that and
yeah while training and with an
electrical engineers and as automatic
some initial hardware designs and always
the equipment equipment from electronics
at one of the electronics and spend
eleven years and then working my way to
party management and had a lot of
opportunity working with earthly largest
the US carriers in in the u.s. from East
Coast to West Coast when was a basin in
the East Coast and then I also also yeah
Jim there's a limit upon us and devices
for a couple of venture capitalists and
also startup companies so that's
basically my bad one
so today the topic is so we're talking
about artificial intelligence so I'd
like to share some of a my view about AI
so to me a
is not differently agent human
intelligence so let's think about this
well so in my opinion artificial
intelligence is not a science or
technology by itself alone it relies on
many many other technologies like a
human intelligence human intelligence is
not just a developer by reading the
books reading the books are feeding the
knowledge --is and starting from a baby
baby it does now develop enough
intelligence to supply feeding baby
something because the physical
development is also very important part
of it physical development helps the
intelligence development in the vice
versa as well so we're talking about
machine learnings in the AI I think it's
going to happen in the same way so that
that's my opinion
I there's no way few of us who can work
on some our artificial intelligence it
involves all the sciences from medicines
of America from computers of electrical
I think from many many areas so that's
the basis for my today's talk you know
what I to set the foundations for why
mention some of this stuff so based on
what my philosophy is so you need to
build an infrastructure which will feed
you to build a next generation where
artificial intelligence so what we need
many many things
it's like developing a baby to a super
smart person right you need to help it
poverty the baby needs to learn music
helped me learn another language or
something everything helps purely
intelligence so so so I'd like to share
some of the technologies I have seen in
some I read it but most of them are
actually physically see when I spent
nine years in China back and forth
between Washington DC and China so I saw
some of things in China a lot of things
I want to outline some of
so you don't see that many orphans here
but in China
quite visible maybe some of you have a
different view so that that's perfect
fine
and it helped me to develop a my
knowledge base for example the other
seasons for traffic controls here we're
starting you all these are cameras and
stuff in China that happens quite long
ago ten years ago they already stopped
putting all the sensors on every streets
in the control sir ten years ago the
streetlights always already LEDs we're
happy came back in the u.s. we're still
using light bulbs or fluorescent light
bulbs in China it's already LEDs it
happens very very quickly once they have
led developer it looks at all of their
salad and I went to every sharp source
why so what is a spark so everything so
LED how could I have a mirror fast
because portable reason was China has to
their tenancy where some things are hot
like everybody going after that and plus
the government incentives that also
helps now long term maybe a little bit
different story but that's what it is
the the the parking you traveling to the
parking garage like I did at today's
that are Tonto funny and produced by in
China you almost everywhere you go into
it will tells you how many amputee slots
there and then there's a rare lights and
the green lights on each of us value it
is a follow the sign and it's very easy
so you don't have to driving around to
find those things that happens in 87
nine years ago and since I left the
China three years ago so 10 years ago
they're already there and it's not just
one place or two plays it's a many many
places in many many cities
security cameras everybody I think there
are hundreds and a million similar
security cameras in China somebody from
the US and the data experiment try to
escape and they found out there's no way
because it has a camera and that's
chasing the very well you can cut it
there's no way I can scared in China if
I'd this something better facial
recognition that's another part of the
fundamental technologies
or building artificial intelligence and
I can tell you in 2006 when Linda a
Shanghai I find a company and they said
they're working on facial recognition at
a 2006 it was a pretty early within that
puppy I went to visit them they said
yeah we're developing software
I said who needed this thing what's that
useful we said Oh a US company needs
today so that was in 2006 a small
company shall have was a developing
facial recognition sir for a u.s.
customer I don't know who there is they
wouldn't show me it wouldn't tell me who
that is so so these things that happens
in a while you see all these things
happen can't help it
artificial intelligence in this city low
cost of 3G 4G mobile services in China
happen sauce a long time ago everybody
buy these little SIM cards and the
Pauline with the USB dongle so they can
take your computers everywhere there
helps to connecting all the IOT devices
together to build a foundation for
artificial intelligence a big data
analytics you need all the sensors
everywhere so what what do we need that
you need a battery to power these the
wireless sensors we also need a wireless
connections to connect all of them
together so these things also happens
and by rapidly solar we energy and the
city I was living in Shenzhen I'm pretty
sure other cities that have the same
thing that the whole streets of with
3040 miles long you know all the
streetlights were powered by the
combination of of solar and the wind
because of the only the datum is a use
of solar at the night time we it's a
pretty fascinating and transportation
high-speed chase everybody luma EVs
I actually went to a sentence for four
months ago in July I believe and they
told me I before I say I saw probably
10% over the taxes are evey electrical
vehicles this time almost a half of us
they said by next year this time and a
hundred percent of the taxes will be
Electrical so mobile payments everybody
probably heard about this in China you
don't even need a cache and from tier 1
to tier 3 cities it's almost every city
has a small city programs in the
mandates some are costs themselves with
drivers and if I do all these companies
are doing that pretty pretty amazing and
also a lot of small companies doing very
well
and I want to talk about one thing talk
about the data center so here's a status
number US and China two countries have a
fifty-five percent of the data in the
worldwide US as a 45 percent of it the
data is in the globally
China has a ten percent so these two
countries occupiers have pretty much a
50% 55% of the data centers worldwide in
the last three years more than half of
the new dealers in this built by
Microsoft why because everybody
uploading your powerpoints or
documentation so to 360 so they need to
build the data centers everywhere in the
world so more than half of it ain't
mutator saying this at Microsoft
okay so you massaman in China I want to
quickly go through this way these are
the highlights for where the government
or the private money is a way into it
national high speed the Train building
backbone so that that's a pretty much a
completed they are adding more segments
here there but the backbone is already
there subway systems are almost advising
you or the major cities they all have a
subway system sadena
the big cities are adding one more than
the small cities the second year 30
years and they are actually start
building a subway systems 45 G's it's a
pretty amazing everywhere and
except the US Travel is a little bit
painful because our chips don't work in
their low cost is another thing in
in four months that's about less than $2
a month you can have a little mobile
data devices that will connect to your
mobile device to somewhere in the cloud
smart grid development and all images
are talked about in local EPS are
putting lots lots of a monitoring points
in every major cities down to every
counties to want to build in their
workers so they can trace and monitor
manager the pollutions lots and lots of
a government sponsorships and the
programs and plus a lot and they are in
the machine learning all these things
that happen at the same time some
conclude my report basically all these
things the little things to hear the
India all these actually become a big
investment to form the next generation
to support the next generation of
artificial intelligence it's all needed
it so don't pan out hopefully one thing
can make that happen so last minute and
I would like to share two programs our
project Archimedean controls and
actually worked it together with our
sales channel partners in China we
actually last year we actually this year
we actually install our smart
monitoring system for 35 full corn
granary warehouses in China I wouldn't
mention where it is and before that it's
all manually down so bring these are big
green houses each one is about 16 meters
around which is about 180 feet long and
20 60 feet wide then a 8 meter which is
a 24 feet tall these are huge was then
they just sat on pinnacle you see these
little windows on the top there's no
then you just a ton for your your weeds
or whatever cones inside and we help
them to develop a monetary system for
twenty four five seven to feed all their
big data analytics within artificial
intelligence
so they can particular for example if
with the surrounding area so the the
forest and caught a fire so they know
that so they can actually warm or the
one or these the places that hey there's
a ten miles away there's a forest so far
this event files you need to do
something about it so we saw the data is
available everywhere from every sinner
every census thing it helps the people
to feel that your intelligence there's a
lot of imagination you can happen to do
that another things I'd like to mention
that and also early last year and we've
worked with the u.s. city only out of
the Washington DC and one the the things
I didn't know about that you sto in the
China Theo he actually had a touring
program after both Obama and I believe
it was a xi jinping sign off or Paris
agreement a year ago so most countries
either join your program the condition
was China will provide the market US
will provide the technology in the
products the condition for you as a
participator is everything must be
designed that develop within the
building in the US you cannot have any
Chinese components in there everything
must be building in the US of China
agreed on that so we participated around
this program and we actually won a deal
sort of with the help of from the do e
USC do we so like to share with you and
this is a we helped a customs build data
center to save about 24% of our energies
as a part of the small city programs so
that concludes my sherry and thank you
very much thank you
[Applause]
it's amazing how much has been done but
I have to remember our note that we'll
talk about this later I was trying to
sell LED streetlights to cities in China
in 2006 and 7 Shenzhen already had it
you said but Beijing did not and who now
did not and even Shanghai did not so we
were you know it doesn't all happen at
once no great progress yeah Chinese
River China is a future market the
answer fragment in the market yeah so
don't don't think I always have been
mocking in China yeah it is a bigger
like a restaurant it's a huge amok it
like I still have to deal with each
individual restaurant so they don't know
where the restaurant right so now we
have young Mimi who's lived a lot in
China worked with the gas company power
and power and all he's got a lot of
experience I come from China I work in
China National Petroleum Corporation and
I'm lucky here I'm a visiting fellow in
the Pacific center here my Pecola is I
started my job is a computer program in
system management for the 1980s in the
time I work for changes in China
National Petroleum Corporation we have
the pitches the my frame in China import
from IBM this is a picture I took from
the silicones Computer History Museum in
these kinds of computers we have many
kinds of rig in from 2001 to 2008
accompanied the times in 2001 I found
they as a very big tranches for ITV no
jeez maybe like this time for a I can
all
there are many new startups in idealism
especially in e-commerce market as you
know is the Chico Mass Ave palette ham
there are many new startups in many
certain linear program in in the lead
time I find I found at accompanies
Allium it is which fit a key technology
companies in in it
this company has become the peaches all
your IT companies is about three
thousand stars in our company we have
opened the some companies in in Dubai in
Canada in Haskell firm in this in Latino
Center is run by the chief it is maybe
one of the richest company or names
datacenter pre welcome datacenter this
is maybe one of the maybe the top ten in
Recife has the fourth on digital smart
olofi solution for many years it
performs live sky life cycle monument of
force base real-time or expiration in
production so little mega business
process can be optimized in TVC freeway
cloud is biologist data center but is in
Miami all the smart
artists I am somehow within smash cities
have the same data types of data
processes you have to to acquisition to
the Machine vanishes in elastic to give
interest to make up your equipments in
net your companies are your city's more
safe training which we see is due to
intense of China's multi contrasting
projects only one hand cities are
looking for comprehensive strong company
to take the lead in projects because
masochists they have any different areas
very complicated you have to link all
the letters to let them to in the same
platform so always you have to be to
design the total projects on the other
hand which we decided to expand its
business outside our industry so ago
our company is such that our smart city
projects smart sudhi and this is a small
city architecture all the same maybe
there are many different kinds of smart
cities plan but all this Samina the
lower is the hardware is in transfer is
to make the audience to perception
communication in then if cloud computing
data center yeah in data layers the main
function is to do the data exchanges
ciemins in the enter all the data is
have the same gender into stored in the
same data center sometimes the
distribution in must have assumed Edison
surrenders there in application layers
always different because you have to
build a system or a system or at least
water for the pump water city's needs
different cities have different urban
development plan maybe some cities near
beautiful scenery they want with your
efforts tourism so you some cities they
have focus on the smart tourism in some
cities maybe near port inland you have
to build a smart port for a city with
different kinds of applications in top
of layers city operations in command
centers before now there are many cities
are building of these kinds of centers
the Tresor take data together in little
different departments of people to work
together in the same big room
sometimes the cities sometimes she teach
the commandment is very big you know
many many videos many squares layer and
this is Allah the mighty series
architecture in Phi happens in China's
mass cities before the some speeches is
talking about this concert just quickly
construe about me about mourning 500
mass cities under contrasting but I
think almost every city in China
studying or help incident to work with
the best summer city sometimes I am it
with some me years before in Lin they
all are talking about the AI talking
about cloud computing the polymer cities
here truly tell true they have no any
idea about Utley apology but they always
hope to make the city to be more smarter
to be the web more sustainable so if you
really need big changes that you can go
to for IT people to go to to go to the
city to talk with really high level
mayor's in Austria you know about the
Ali Baba's City plan parties now they
have using the are you team AI problems
to make some to take all the control the
signal lights in the end you can
you can always can detect the accidents
so this had a say last year Alibaba is
chief in Hangzhou city's the last the
accuracy is to to find some acetone
series about the ninety or ninety
percent accuracy it's much better than
before
any other small example for Richfield we
have the cheerful in Fujian city is a
very very small cities in China only
about 150 thousand population layer
local located near Russian order but
presidency two years ago has been to
this small city but the mayor I met with
him many times they decide to to make
very big investment in smash cities to
catch up with the total Corinne faster
in our areas pala mile deliverables for
these projects is a design of the smash
city's IT infrastructure such as related
measures with me as a minister
sensitivity have no in idea about Haiti
so they always some families when they
are in have sampling or medicine
projects but I think the most important
to make total IT plane or airplane for
the city - according to his urban
European the wagon plane so the forces
of the brain inland is we build a
control and command center in data
center in law that if it is surrounded
by Wien chef is always we build some
city management in services systems a
fool who has mass it is first airbase to
make a unified plan and build unify the
data center in control center I think
after the first part of our projects in
SD step with the help of integrated the
platforms incorrectly that the small
city will come true so I just give a
brief intro Italian but because this
class is top isvara but I think I in
China especially in some a city is
adjusted to begin first about 10 years
morning 10 years every city is talking
about smashy teachers to build the
software platform to connect the data
together to converse their mini daemon
process into computer platform in now I
think this is just the begin to a are
you notice so this is my speeches thank
you very much
thank you so it's it's getting popular
it's kidding is making a difference but
it's very complicated
right there are lots of data that have
to be managed and how do we get people
and computers to work together for a
better result so what questions do you
have for the speakers yes
the fundamental agreement on the
structure of the data and the interfaces
that are needed any protocols that are
new people benefit from like to get a
little bit about that interfaces between
all the data okay
that's been pretty much I mean we're
getting standardizing it but - yeah yeah
I can't just speak up from my
perspectives currently there's as far as
I can tell there's no specific
interfaces standard - just for small
city and the city application just
adopted what's already existed and a lot
of my family I tu from A to Z ITU got
tons of other students from a Dhawan a
tattoo all the way to seed a few
hundreds and that defines the most sort
of the standard interfaces between how
the device again communicated for
example tcp/ip is a one of element
everybody used that so there is no need
to talk about upper body to agree I do
think they should develop a something
which is not there today there's really
no standards between smart devices this
one can plug into the other one unless
you use one of these typical
communication standards protocol
interface even the connectors might be
different about and I think as time goes
on if oh there's a consortium can build
the ones were definitely helped yeah so
standards
a lot of experience with standards even
trying to get language all different
languages on one computer if you don't
agree on the standard you can't do it
and if you already have carved out of
your space than you think this is my
space but what we learned from building
Unicode is that when we use standards
actually everybody makes more money they
get more done and they are happier about
the results so standards are critical
but at this stage remedy were just
trying something new right so what is
your experience yeah in China yeah it's
a very difficult or they are too many
kinds of data but in China is I think is
different from the United States because
many things are opposed by government so
many always some users and have a gamma
who will take some new standard in many
companies are one path as all companies
become is so thus attainder skimpy can
be a probably wider you can be used
widely so in now the sampica companies
who state have a data exchange platform
layer mm-hmm according to the according
to the national standards are in turkey
standards our four cities signal it's
winter so I think so I in my mule in
China in future I think is much easier
to push all the new behind in oh geez
because theta first have been stained de
satinder dyes mm-hmm
so China it's much easier as you said
and yet they have their own language
their own way of doing things and they
want to be part of the rest of the world
so we do need to have international
standards and I'm finding in the
building standards
right you got lead Sanders and you got
ASHRAE standards and that China has
their own standards and they're trying
to find ways to make them work together
synchronize them but one standard can be
translated into another once you do that
then everybody can work together IBM had
petabytes of data and in Arabic and
other languages that they had invented a
coding system but they joined the
Unicode consortium after they realized
that well they had all that done but
they still needed to work for the rest
of the world so they joined us they put
in millions of dollars to help us
develop that standard and of course we
had to compromise what their standard to
find a translation for it yes they
should talk a lot about autonomous
vehicles but it would appear that China
would have a great advantage because
it's actually building brand-new cities
from scratch and in the u.s. you know
you're going to go to 1% of the cars in
a particular city being autonomous and
eventually at some point in 20 years or
30 years 100% being autonomous but China
doesn't have to worry about that problem
in brand-new cities they can just say
that all the cars will either be
autonomous where all the cars will be
sensors if they're not autonomous they
actually can talk to other cars what's
the perspective in terms of local
transport and autonomous vehicle shared
vehicles and deep you see China taking
advantage of the fact that it's got
brand-new cities that don't have the old
interpreter and having to work with two
different set of standards while they're
building news is not totally from
scratch new cities they're converting
their cities but one of the things I
heard of becoming autonomous vehicles
are not the future they're part of the
future but they're building high-speed
rail they're building
you know better communities where people
can walk to work or they can walk walk
to the shop and so forth too many cars
autonomous are not they're gonna be dead
eight right wait I'm not sure pardon
said producers but you say producer okay
okay ours I think something like
eighteen to twenty million cars a year
the US is actually used to be number one
but it isn't so yeah they have one point
four billion people so it's not
everybody has a car or even half so it's
it's a something I mean that the problem
is to think more broadly autonomous
vehicles yes that's part of the solution
high-speed rail is part of the solution
right better subways and better public
transit all those things have to work
together
public transit issue is the last mile
but you know when I was living in
Beijing wonder network and I'm we're
living there in 1980 we could get
everywhere faster on bicycle than by bus
or taxi and when I went back in 86 87 is
still public transportation was better
but driving I wouldn't want to drive it
there I mean the traffic is so bad right
I'd much rather use public transit if I
could and in fact when I moved to New
York City I sold my car I mean who wants
a car in New York City okay
it's just a headache people break into
it you can't get anywhere anyway it's
just a headache
I've much rather ride the trolley ride
the subway and so forth so we did to
think more broadly about that right
yeah I don't think autonomous vehicles
are going to become a massive
transportation tools in near term I
think it's just like artificial
intelligence it takes a bunch of
adjacent technology to be developed in
the same times and also today if you
look at the the safety measurements and
we put in every single car today
actually was a result of how from many
many years how many people were killed
right there each time when we develop a
little bit more at another safety issue
changing the law or the traffic controls
or the streetlights or design today
numbers society is under for even our
legal system the core system number
things are a designer for all of us
drive self-driving car at the massive
scale what I'm talking about now there's
always a sweet spots in each market so
maybe you can use it here there but when
I would say 80% over the castle sale
free driving I think it's a good to take
a time and there's a big hurdle this is
the legal system or illegal traffic
control there's so many things a it
takes to kill as well as some ways they
can sue few people back so I know
kenitra market it's always everything
has a signature market but become a
massive media cause it's going to take
somebody I think I was just on the way I
was here saw somebody from here say that
it's going to be next 20 years it's not
good man niche market for autonomous
vehicles is getting from home to the
train station getting home to this bus
station right Oh baby eagle community or
something yeah right yeah because maybe
these are the airport and if we could
eliminate half of the parking spaces we
have that much more housing space you
know I was at the Silicon Valley
community senator last night and the
housing as a maze
edek in Silicon Valley they've got more
and more more jobs but no place for
people to live that they can afford
yeah so we have to think a bit more
about you know eliminating parking
spaces building more little spaces and
then transferred back and forth yeah I
think a technology so one side of a
story I I still believe illegals is
another side of its course yeah
without both sides of things that cannot
move forward okay
yes my understanding is in the big
cities in China most people live in
housing high-rise maybe 95% of the
people much different than single-family
housing here so and you just mentioned
we need you know we may need more tips
housing here to handle half here but how
do people in China feel about the u.s.
single-family housing instead of its
housing yeah so I understand the
question so a lot of people ask me that
question so first of all let me say a
few things you have to really compare
Apple to Apple so the people are saying
people in China and living high rise to
the department that talking about the
big city in China Shanghai Beijing
changes its equipment we were talking
about San Francisco City or New York
City yeah most of people arises
apartment or condos but the ruler is a
residence a little bit different in a
single-family rotom thousand in China
it's the same situation so if you
compare that here with city big city to
big city the only being they're mostly
living in a high-rise er
are you talking about countryside and
some rural areas but it's a it's a maybe
the quality is a different but it's all
individual
houses in China it says same situation
well there's a book called happy Cities
by Charles Montgomery one of the things
that he discovered by comparing cities
around the world for a happiness factor
if people can live upstairs go down
stairs and shop and go out to a nearby
park and leave with their friends
they're much happier they have more time
to do those things than trying to drive
somewhere so that's a something that
China has big cities already has down
first florists stores right yeah hey
I have a wall cities like in New
York I think I want to give a little bit
different perspective okay no a small
city in China we're talking about five
million people and here we have but to
say Jose it's different because here we
as San Jose have a huge land but a
probably a couple billion people yeah so
San Jose has 1 million wait yes
population of China and you know very
fast growth or let's say a smart cities
and yeah what will happen to the
prospect of job and also centrally
controlled every data then what will
happen
to people's privacy is there going to be
any backlash because me because of these
two reasons in future also very what
will happen but saying I can use to and
partly my perspective of China is
basically they are very centralized in
the monitoring the people and so face
through facial this recognition and many
other things right now in fact they will
be able to detect whether you
participate in any undesirable
activities then from there then you will
have in will be not be able to travel
you know or not
get a good education you're not going to
be able to get a good job so to me is
1984 in real life but it happened in
that way and I think the control is in
some ways people think is necessary
because it's such a large country and
stability is extremely important for the
country so I think that part of the AI
will be very very fast developing yeah
well we also have even in San Jose
they're creating four times as many jobs
every year as housing units so people
they get a job they have no place to
live have to commute from the East Bay
or they have to try to a lot of people
have become homeless they just can't
afford to live there because more jobs
but not enough places to live so people
would rather have a place to live that's
close to their work and their family and
friends
so being crowded is okay if it's
convenient but an AI can help with that
I mean look at all the stuff that's done
with traffic right when I was living in
Beijing people would turn off their
lights at night when they're driving
because they didn't want to blind the
other driver yeah they would but you're
getting anywhere was a major headache
because they didn't even understand
technology of driving cars on the street
so you know technology can help with
that artificial intelligence and and
human intelligence right we have to
learn what works what doesn't and
certainly I always loved riding my bike
everywhere because I got there faster
than but have any other way that's as
far away yeah the thing was amazing me
was a the humans our ability to learn to
adapt some new things amazing fast yeah
and in the early eighties right yeah I
saw some places for example in Shanghai
big city they they wanted to build a
3,000
buildings first thing I thought they'd
never build us actually how can they
find a world the people to design the
building super building you never did it
this way only building will store two
stories in your lifetime so many how can
you all of a sudden want to build a 50s
for all buildings you never done that
but amazing enough most of our people
the first generation these are building
walkers
they've never done anything like that
but they did it so that amazes me you
never did this man I wouldn't give this
job to you but since then nobody has it
so it takes whoever the police it very
versatile inside the way I tried it okay
you try it and they eventually probably
after few times they failed and they did
it this way so now have the 20-30 years
it's like a building a hundred storey
building China's nobody almost anybody
can do oh yeah amazingly it's not just a
China I think in the USA of course so
human has a amazing ability to learn new
things that you may be fool I never did
that before
yeah I think you had a question you know
so with the standardization of control
here you have mechanisms for keeping
updated and keeping the system modern do
you understand the question immature
Watson efficiency it's a cynical ding ah
yes I just I thought about smash it
easily the poppy pig by the big
companies for example prepare so he is a
state-owned company in we have a nation
our country always in every industry
have were strangers they are any new is
just a total we we have for beauty
some kind of a data exchange platform on
the
and in the system in a platform in all
the data have we have the link to change
it data we said platform in n1 okay so
first we have standards and then we have
a platform data exchange platform or for
exchanges sometimes they almost yes it's
a good or the other team for this kind
of organization and this this this group
of people they always to change modifier
material some new some new needs coming
you have to modify the codes inside
platform in the pre in a platform is to
sell to all the all companies to for
example maybe there's a new project
folder one city in the emini companies
to work for it
she killed right in in all the all the
companies come here have to exchange you
the data with the data center to
exchange with so the data called
platform layer so there so this kind of
platform layer well I think one of the
issues I mean China is changing so fast
and China has this concept called wedgie
the word for crisis and Chinese means
danger and opportunity so it's like look
at the danger and you freeze and you
lose you look at the opportunity you
grab it you move it move ahead but there
are big companies everywhere right and
too much of a monopoly can be a problem
and look at American oil companies they
kept a British Petroleum changed their
name to beyond petroleum but did they
move beyond petroleum no because they've
been doing it the old way so a lot of
people get stuck in their old way
doing things and a big company is harder
to change but things are changing so
fast nowadays they so we have to really
adopt that attitude fail it forward move
ahead look for the opportunity try it
out right yeah most of the state-owned
enterprises are monopolies I think you
mr. Lee's China National Petroleum
Company is also a monopoly yeah there's
not so many different kinds of brands
for oil yes what they learned to adapt
anyway wait
that's good okay I think you had a
question of them yeah yeah standing has
been so fun a smart city projects there
is always government funding and then
also some kind of sponsorship from the
government so has there been in China
any Smart City project where there has
been no government involvement see how
already evolved a kind of a profitable
business model where only private
companies are not actually beginning to
engage with the city yeah
you can answer smart cities yeah any any
profitable sparse cities in China profit
funded probably yeah privately funded so
I mean yeah yeah they are now there are
some pre-work come more creative surely
Analia many projects are always built by
poverty companies in Ravello competed
together per family always state-owned
company always very big but in here much
more money right - maybe if you want to
be mix em - to some IT policy have to
enough France may be true to support in
name but always the Proteas many kinds
of company what Takeda be so very
difficult for the somatic isn't women
areas so there are many kinds of
specialized IT
I'm saying especially initially to avoid
a family so he's a no problem but now a
strangely some new companies in wasted
by happy companies in Twitter family
together now there are many no kind of
new status maybe yes so I I've been
working with Steve Chen with the
supercomputers he's going around China I
can he just explains to the local this
cities and the local companies that
would benefit from having a better data
system shared data and then eventually
they get on board and they fund it not
top-down government funding but then
they have to get government approval
anyway right it's pretty the whole idea
is to build up enough momentum and the
desire for the result because you can
demonstrate this benefit and then you
can get all kinds of people on board I
would say there are surprises they may
not be labeled as a small cities but
actually they are not necessarily a
water project they have to put the
labels on that I actually saw a company
they actually took a little self 3d
scanner depths camera and they take care
every parts of it your beauty your my
father you know your switches your
doorknob so they take a pictures and
they're putting into the database so as
I'm a water you do this this is a well
so every technician circum you want to
repair that those hello this atoll RK is
a broken then what do you do are you one
so way to I buy what's the problem who
is the manufactured what's the cost is
there other who are your camera mobile
phone so again that take a picture of
that center to your to the database the
database to come back okay your order
from this company is the part number
keys because of how many pieces that's
here oh that's a some tackle some are
silly
yeah oh never thought about that I mean
there are so many things
yeah okay
way back in the corner there so since
most other Smurfs cities are government
companies was the current state of
sharing theater private enterprises and
what's the future of that as well in
China future of sharing data private
enterprises this must if you do there's
always a balancing act right but you
have to show the benefit ultimately the
public benefit then people will
eventually see why they should share it
but it doesn't happen just like that of
course the Chinese government has
control of more data like facial
recognition and all that stuff but
actually for not committing crimes it's
not bad I can see that or the other side
yeah it's not awkward at all the data
are controlled by a counter yeah if
common want to open the data to the
society is much more easier because
garner China China common only justify
order to all the state-owned enterprises
all the data I think he'll be open to
more widely is much easier now there are
some big projects the Intel sharing
protesters now are post directly by
Premier Li indication he's pushing many
big platforms to let all the data to
share his own as I see it it's depend on
what editors finally the thinking about
so I think is mataji's so in my view in
future AI now is sort this year the AI
investment is for strategies
much morning united states that this
year in in so I think yeah awesome ICT
infuse in the next few years to go very
fast on something so bottom line would
go back to our original observation
about smart city and big data is that
there's so much data there's no way one
organization or one person could control
it we need to have the data available
and then manage how we could use it to
improve situations right and so making
it public data or public organizations
at it then they can solve problems
better because they have it right but it
has to be broken down I mean yeah a lot
of decisions have to be made within one
second right you're gonna try to give
that to some official to make that
decision that doesn't make sense
I might have like with PG and E's fire
right with they didn't even know where
the pipe was broken it took them a while
to figure it out so that that's not a
good way to handle those things right
gotta have the data I make it available
turn the switch off no more gas going
than the fire stops okay it looks like
we run out of time we need to we can
continue the conversation outside and
have something to eat as well thank you
[Applause]